as the richest of the world continue to
grow their wealth year after year
it raises the question where do they
even get all of this money most of the
billionaires we are familiar with are
tech mogul z-- who owned various tech
companies who services we use on a
regular basis but this is not the
majority of planers in fact tech burners
only account for 9% of all burners so
word to the other 91% get their money
[Music]
starting off by far the biggest source
of donors wealth is finances and
investments with 15% of all billionaires
coming from this sector this includes
your classic Wall Street burners but
also people you might not have expected
like Bill Gates it is not clear whether
Bill Gates is classified in this
category or not but most of his wealth
is held in this category and has been
for quite a while often times after
becoming billionaires many people simply
want step away from the stress and
responsibility of managing this much
money so they liquidate their assets and
delve into financial realm such is the
case with Bill Gates as he only owns 1.4
percent of Microsoft though this is
worth over 10 million dollars this only
accounts for roughly 15% of his net
worth the majority of his money is kept
in an investment firm he started in 1995
called cascade investments since then
his net worth has jumped from 5 billion
to over 90 billion dollars but if he
simply held on to Microsoft stock he
owned during their IPO he would actually
be worth well over 500 billion dollars
today despite this clearly he's very
satisfied with what he has and I think
it's also very pleased to work his fund
manager Michael Larson has done so not
only to hedge fund managers claim their
fortune through finances but many
builders maintain their fortune here
next up we have fashion and retail which
accounts for 12% of all billionaires of
course this includes owners of top
retail chains like Jeff Bezos and the
walton family but this also includes
many figures who are probably not
familiar with like Berner Arnold
Bernhard Arnold is a CEO of Louis
Vuitton and though he has taken a hefty
loss due to the recent market crash he
is still number 4 on the list and was
the third person to reach a net worth of
100 billion dollars similarly Amancio
Ortega the owner of zara and owners of
other leading fashion brands make the
list moving on we have real estate which
accounts for 9% of billionaires most of
these burners actually come from China
as China accounts for 58% of related
brainers which has been largely fueled
by recent mega urbanization in China in
the u.s. the wealthiest real estate
investor is Donald Byrne who owns
airline company which is a real estate
development firm based in California and
of course we have Donald Trump and many
others as well next up we have
technology that makes up 9% of all
billionaires and really needs no
explanation
yeah Mark Zuckerberg Larry Page Sergey
Brin Larry Ellison and so on and so
forth the next category is manufacturing
which also makes him nine percent of all
billionaires this includes people such
as Terry go who is a man who found her
Foxconn the largest manufacturing
company in the world with revenue
topping four point seven trillion
dollars in the US the top manufacturing
billionaire is Charles Koch who is the
owner of the second largest private US
company Koch Industries who specializes
in chemical manufacturing based in
Kansas moving on we have diversified
billionaires who make up 8% of worldwide
billionaires these guys are basically
venture capitalists they're not looking
for 7 to 10 percent returns year after
year like financial guys but rather
hundreds or thousands of percent of ROI
over a long period of time the best
example of this would be Warren Buffett
and his company Brookshire Hathaway just
40 years ago Warren Buffett was not even
a blender he was worth about 200 million
dollars and while this is a lot of money
start off with and a long time frame the
return is still incredible because in
this time period
Warren Buffett was money 400 fold in
this same time period
an average hedge fund or mutual fund
would have only produced a 20 to 25 fold
return if that this is things the Warren
Buffett unbelievable returns of 17.1%
per year since 1985
next up 8% of worldwide billionaires
come from food and beverage these
burners on the largest fast-food and
restaurant chains as well as popular
snack and beverage brands this includes
people like Dan Kathy the owner of
chick-fil-a and John Tyson the owner of
Tyson Foods moving on we have healthcare
which accounts for 6 percent of
worldwide billionaires this includes
owners of national hospital chains as
well as owners of pharmaceutical
companies you are probably at least
familiar with the donors from this
sector as the usual work behind the
scenes and don't get much media coverage
of course an infamous lady from the
sector would be Elizabeth Holmes who
fooled the world that she could conduct
blood tests with just a single drop of
blood when her fraud was exposed her
fortune dropped from 4.5 billion to 0
following up we have the energy sector
which accounts for 4% of worldwide
billionaires many familiar billionaires
have big investments in this field like
Elon Musk
warren buffett and richard branson but
the people who derived most of their
wealth from this field are also
relatively unknown like alice Wabun was
a hundred percent stake in an Archon and
finally we have media and entertainment
which accounts for 4% no actors have
reached boner status with the wealthiest
actor being sharkon with a net worth of
six hundred million dollars this list is
mostly made up of production and media
company owners and some directors like
Steven Spielberg and George Lucas this
sector mainly includes people like
Rupert Murdoch the owner of News Corp
which owns Fox News but even all of this
only accounts for 84 percent of donors
and the rest are from other fields
evidently bilious rise out of all sorts
of sectors not just Wall Street or tech
though they are the most well known and
the fact that the majority of burners
are self-made is just more proof that
people can be vastly successful in any
field given the right direction and
perseverance if you guys thought this
video provided a thorough analysis of
the world's billionaires
then make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you let see more
questions just like this one logically
answered but until then I'm hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one